il s'appelle recèle antonio
urrutikoetxea mais depuis toujours on le
surnomme rosso ternira il est considéré
comme le patron de l'organisation
séparatiste basque eta fin des années 80
des séparatistes basques eux multiplient
les attentats en espagne
1987 une voiture piégée à saragosse
bilan 11 morts
josu ternera est soupçonné par le
gouvernement espagnol d'avoir commandité
cet attentat deux ans plus tard alors en
planque en france il est arrêté par les
renseignements généraux français des
policiers espagnols et français sont la
tête baissée you should ternera va subir
ses premiers interrogatoires il est jugé
en 1989 pour association de malfaiteurs
mais n'est pas inquiété à cette époque
pour les attentats de saragosse il sera
emprisonné en france jusqu'en 1996
aujourd'hui égoïste étaient venus
jusqu'à muret pour soutenir son père à
travers les murs de la prison comme il
l'a fait donc décidé de ne pas le voir
1996 fin de sa peine en france mais la
police l'attend à la sortie de prison et
le transfert à la frontière pour le
remettre aux autorités espagnoles terme
ra serait selon la police espagnole
l'initiateur et le spécialiste des
attentats à la voiture piégée il est
considéré comme un dur de letea
l'espagne demande son extradition depuis
90 deux ans plus tard malgré son
incarcération en espagne il sera élu
député au parlement basque et c'est là
toute l'ambiguïté du personnage
terroristes pour certains pour d'autres
il est l'artisan de la paix entre
espagnols et indépendantistes
l'hôtel et survie de stationnaire
il est libéré en 2000
mais deux ans plus tard la justice
espagnole le convoque de nouveau alors
il entre dans la clandestinité
la cavale commence les polices française
et espagnole sont à ses trousses
à cette époque pour certains
spécialistes terme ra joue encore un
rôle dans le terrain les généraux et le
maréchal ont été arrêtés donc il n'ya
plus personne il faut aller chercher les
vieux de la vieille ceux qui ont
combattu avec eta ya vingt ans et en
premier lieu aux éternels rossouw
ternera qui apparaît aujourd'hui comme
l'homme de la relève ancien député du
parlement basque ancien dirigeant de
théa il est en fuite depuis 2002 et a
déjà passé huit ans en prison la cavale
de josu ternera se termine en 2019 en
savoie entre temps le thé a été dissoute
jugé en son absence pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes
il a demandé à être rejugé une fois ces
procédures judiciaires françaises
terminé il sera extradé en espagne
[Musique]